le moyeu les filles les feux nous
gouvernent et les hommes rêvent tous
d'aller au bar quand on va partir tous
les matins détendre je pars plus parce
que je veux aller au bal de la grande
beune riz est choisi par la colonelle et
avoir plein de petites filles avec m
jacky fait la sieste maudit nontron
m'appelle pas ton temps tu crois
l'hôtellerie ou quoi nous voyons des
filles les hommes s'habillent de belles
voilerie pour plaire à la princesse
charmant alors lui ces versions
il a 19 ans et les dépôts ou les
sublimer g fit lui ai pas fait attention
à toi arrête de rien et ce sont les
femmes qui portent culotte 1
une femme comme les autres jours je t'ai
organisé une fête le disparaît donnant
de fausses perles excellence toi tu veux
que je te parle
bienvenue dans un monde merveilleux un
monde où les hommes et les femmes vivent
enfin en parfaite harmonie
car ces charmants la timidité jacky au
royaume des filles m'ont pas dit s'ils
ont regardé le 29 janvier